breaking news out of New York okay
Manhattan Grand Jury has voted to indict
former presidents Donald Trump over
alleged hush money he paid to the adult
film star Stormy Daniels during his 2016
presidential campaign let's bring in our
U.S correspondent James Matthews joining
us now from DC so James uh good to have
you with us we expected this was coming
Donald Trump told us as much but now the
news is out that the grand jury voted to
indict
that's right Kamali yeah what he turned
right in relation to that hush money
payment as you say hush money isn't a
crime in itself but the crime was or the
crime the prosecutors have been looking
at was the force falsification of
Records in the Trump organization
basically Donald Trump although he
denies it is said to have had an affair
with a porn star Stormy Daniels in 2006.
just days before the 2016 election which
he won he was concerned that she was
going to go public with that story he
asked his fixer his former lawyer
Michael Cohen to pay Stormy Daniels 130
000 which he Julie did and it was in the
repayment to Cohen for that hush money
that's the crime that the prosecutors
are looking at they reckon that that was
put through the books as something else
he is facing a sealed indictment what we
will find out when that is unsealed is
the extent to which that impacts on the
laws of campaign Finance because therein
will lie the felony upgrading a
misdemeanor to a felony upgrades the
crime it upgrades the potential
punishment from a maximum of one year in
jail to four years in jail now this is
historic and it and it will be quite the
spectacle should a former president a
possible future president turns up in a
courthouse in lower Manhattan to face
criminal charges it's never happened in
this country's history it will be quite
the spectacle much will need to be
worked out in terms of security and
Logistics but to all intents and
purposes the Trump camps say they're
quite happy for him to appear much as
any common criminal does in that
building in New York's Bowery to be
fingerprinted to have of his mug shot
taken indeed they see a positive
political impact in this Trump himself
you'll remember he was the man that at
10 or so days ago put on his social
media site he was the man that said he
was going to be arrested on the back of
that he raised more than a million and a
half dollars in funds it stirs the Trump
base for him to be portrayed as the
victim and that's how he clearly intends
to play this as a political Witch Hunt
as a weaponization of the justice system
don't forget Kamali this is not the only
aspect of legal Jeopardy that he is
facing indeed this indictment will be
the least of his worries possibly when
you look at the other potential charges
that our investigations into alleged
attempts to overturn the outcome of the
2020 election in the state of Georgia an
investigation into his role in the
January the sixth Insurrection also
investigations into the mishandling of
classified documents at his home in
Mar-A-Lago in Florida so he's a man who
you know is carrying a lot of legal
Freight behind him and it opens up this
discussion and to how somebody in that
position can proceed towards a
presidential campaign but it's it's
remarkable it is historic remarkably you
have serious media organization writing
broadcasting serious articles about the
practicalities of somebody run running
for president becoming president if they
have a conviction if for example they
are in prison absolutely unprecedented
but that's where we are with Donald
Trump and the circumstances in which he
finds himself the circumstances that uh
that you know he finds himself staring
down the barrel of what is a serious
criminal charge that will seriously
hamper him in terms of his future
ambitions